et maintenant Stéphane Guillon alors
c'est Paris
vous avez suivi un petit peu les
candidats après le après le premier tour
premier tour c'est Patrice alors on
commence par un moment d'émotion mardi
au QG du FN Marine tient la main de son
papa avant son départ en maison de
retraite
l'hospice long séjour accueillera
Jean-Marie mots croisés pétanque et
soirée théâtrale avec Dieudonné
en exclusivité les premières photos de
Jean-Marie allospice là l'infirmière lui
tend ses pilules il grimace un peu plus
tard en survêt pour l'animation poterie
et macramé et voici ces deux camarades
de Chambray Geneviève et Marie-Louise
qu'il vient de nommer responsable de la
section Déambulateur et son urinaire
on termine par une photo de sa fille
sortant de l'hospice marine visiblement
soulagée de cette débarrassée du vieux
le leader frontiste furieux contre
Nicolas Sarkozy qu'il accuse de plagiat
c'est un peu vrai quand Jean-Marie rend
hommage au cow-boy de brokebeck Mountain
15 jours plus tard Nicolas limite
regardez la position du bras c'est bon
une élection rude qui laisse des
séquelles depuis dimanche Philippe de
Villiers se promène avec un drapeau
français sur la tête
au Jardin d'Acclimatation Dominique
Boisnet refuse de quitter la rivière
enchantée
plus grave François Bayrou continue à
faire campagne dans un aéroport il donne
la colade à des militants absents
un peu plus tard il s'est adressé deux
heures à décadis orange la couleur de
son parti après les larmes le réconfort
Nicolas Hulot console de Munich voisnet
en lui touchant les seins
Nicolas qui a l'habitude des missions
difficiles
et puis un beau geste François Bayrou
amoureux des chevaux pardonne à la
monture de Nicolas Sarkozy tu es une
belle [ __ ] lui aurait-il murmurée
autre beau geste le cadeau de
consolation de Vincent Lindon à François
Bayrou un tracteur Smoby avec sa
remorque
après les larmes les regrets Dominique
Boisnet s'interroge voteriez-vous pour
moi si j'étais séropositive non en aucun
cas on aurait voté pour vous à deux pas
de regrets Dominique
émotion toujours vendredi Chirac a
répété son départ de l'Élysée très belle
prestation de Line Renaud
les Chirac ont trouvé un toit 180 m² en
duplex on respire Jacques ne sera pas au
même étage que Bernadette et David
Douillet pourra venir en passant par
l'escalier de service
une image de liesse Neuilly a fêté son
champion une fête énorme qui a failli
dégénérer bien extasie à gogo ce sont
les deux pourcents de logements sociaux
qui ont foutu la merde
et on termine par un scoop Philippe
Torreton et Ségolène le début d'une
romance à quelques minutes après un
entretien privé avec l'acteur une rose
est tombée de la culotte de Ségolène
quel poète se Philippe à la semaine
prochaine
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu